In the last video we saw that
it's not just an issue of one
bank failing.
Because maybe one bank
does fail, some of
its loans come due.
In this case, Bank A
had some loans from
Bank B that come due.
It couldn't liquidate
these assets.
And then it couldn't liquidate
these CDOs for enough money to
pay for this loan.
So Bank A had to go
into bankruptcy.
Then we saw that could create
a whole chain of events.
Then this loan that Bank B had
made to Bank A, the one that
actually precipitated
the event, that had
to be written down.
Because then Bank A is going to
go into bankruptcy and you
don't know how much you're
going to get
back for that loan.
And of course, everybody who
had loans to Bank A, maybe
Bank D had loans to Bank A.
So maybe this asset right here
was also a loan to Bank A.
Everyone with loans to Bank A
all of a sudden gets afraid.
They might have to write
down their assets.
And now, on top of the CDO
problem that we were all
talking about, these smelly
assets that no one wants to
value correctly, on top of that
you have this issue of
these loans that I made to this
other bank, now all of a
sudden those are impaired
assets.
These are assets that probably
aren't worth what I
thought they were.
And so you have this
situation.
One, Bank A was the
last one to fall.
But maybe everyone starts
looking at Bank C next.
And it's usually reflected
in the stock price.
People start shorting the stock,
the stock go starts
going down.
And then Bank C has a situation
where it has some
loan to Bank F, it comes due.
And because its stock price is
going down, no one wants to
lend it money because they say
oh you're just another Bank A,
I'm not going to
lend you money.
No one wants to jump in and give
them equity, no sovereign
wealth fund.
Because you're just going to
go to zero, why would I buy
any stock for even $1 a share
when it's going to go to zero
because your liabilities are
greater than your equity.
So no one wants to
save them either.
And so now, you have this chain
reaction occurring, this
cascade of negative events.
All the banks are afraid to
lend to any other bank.
And you've probably read
articles that the Fed is
injecting liquidity.
What the Fed was doing was, they
were saying, OK, we'll
take some of these assets
that Bank C has.
We'll take them as collateral
and we'll lend you money.
And even if this was horrible
collateral, the Fed just got
very nervous and just started
lending money to anybody.
Anybody who was allowed to
borrow from the Fed.
And I don't know if you
remember, but the
Fed extended it.
Normally, it's just
commercial banks.
But at the beginning of the
credit crisis-- or actually
after the Bear Stearns collapse,
the Fed allowed
investment banks and other
people to start borrowing from
the Federal Reserve directly.
Normally, when the Federal
Reserve lends money to
someone, that person borrows
that money, keeps some of it,
and lends the rest
to someone else.
And so that money enters
the system.
And it allows the actual money
supply to increase.
But what's been happening now
is when banks use this money
to borrow from the Fed or to
borrow any money, they used
these assets as collateral,
they just sit
tight on that cash.
Because they're like, I don't
know what my assets are worth.
I don't know what other of my
assets are going to fail.
When these loans come
due that I owe, I
better have some cash.
Otherwise, I'm just going
to be another Bank A.
So people were borrowing from
the Fed, or borrowing in
general, but they weren't
lending out again.
So that money just kind of
went into a black hole.
So everyone was just sitting
tight on top of their money.
So what's the problem here?
Well clearly, one bank
failure can lead to
multiple bank failures.
Especially if no one's willing
to lend them more money.
So you can say, oh well the only
problem is all of these
banks just fail and who knows
the world might be
better off for that.
Because you won't have all
these people who frankly
aren't making anything.
Although, I don't want
to say that.
Because there is a use for the
financial services sector.
But to some degree a lot of what
happened in the last five
years, they weren't creating
value, they were just
leveraging up and increasing
the risk in the system.
But anyway, let's
put that aside.
So you might say, OK,
worst case, these
banks all go bankrupt.
They get restructured.
But they come back.
The only negative of that
will be that the current
shareholders lose
all their money.
But that's OK, no
risk no return.
There was risk.
And the risk was that your
stock goes to zero.
But then the banks will come
back with new equity.
And then they'll
be back in five
years under new ownership.
You might say that's OK.
What the problem is maybe all of
these banks, there's just a
cascade, they go under.
But not all of these loans
that they make out are to
other banks.
Some of these loans they make
out to the real economy, what
everyone is calling
Main Street now.
Some of these loans they're
making out are to a company
that makes tractors.
Or company maybe it's an
agricultural company that
needs loans to buy seeds for
the next year's crop.
So these are loans that are
actually funneled into the
real economy.
And if every bank is just
sitting on their money, then
these loans aren't going to be
made into the real economy.
Those real companies aren't
going to be able to make
investments, to buy seeds, or
to make a loan to build a
factory for a product that's
actually doing quite well.
And so everyone will
be starved off.
And we'll go into this
massive recession.
Because even though there is
good uses of capital, if you
were to give someone a loan,
they could use that loan to
actually create value by
planting seeds, or
by building a factory.
Those loans aren't available.
Those factories won't
get built.
Those seeds won't get planted.
The farmers will
lay off people.
The factories will
And you could imagine,
we'll go into this
economic down cycle.
So that's what Paulson and
the Federal Service
are concerned about.
Although, some people would
debate that they're more
concerned about the banks
than the real economy.
And they're just using the
real economy as kind of a
sideshow or the rationale.
So what are they arguing
that they want to do?
Well they said the crux of this
issue is, if these $2
billion in CDOs, whatever the
CDOs at any of the banks are
holding, if only the people
could realize the value.
If only this $2 billion that
they have on their books could
be turned into $2 billion
of cash, this
wouldn't be a problem.
Because when these loans come
due, if you believe this $2
billion, then all of these banks
have positive net worth.
They all have positive equity.
And then this whole chain
reaction won't happen.
So when the bailout plan first
came out and they said we'll
create this $700 billion
fund to buy some
of these toxic assets.
and at first they said we'll
buy them at a discount and
we'll hold them to maturity
and then we
might even make a profit.
I said, well that might sound
good, but how's that going to
solve this situation?
Because if you were to go to
this bank and buy the CDOs,
you'd be an idiot to pay $2
billion for them if the market
is only giving, instead
of $2 billion, only
$100 million for them.
Why would you pay $2 billion?
In fact, these $2 billion are
actually based on assumptions
from 2006 when housing prices
can't go down and everyone was
paying off their mortgages.
And everything was rosy.
Those are maybe the assumptions
that drove this $2
billion price.
So if you paid $2 billion for
this asset, sure, you would
save Bank C.
But you would essentially be
buying something that's worth
a lot less.
And even if you held it to
maturity, you're not going to
ever see a present value
of $2 billion.
So when I first read the bailout
proposal, I said
they're going to pay some
discount on that, but that's
not going to help
the situation.
Because let's say these
are only worth
$0.10 on the dollar.
If they paid 10%
of $2 billion.
If the the Fed came in and paid
$200 million for this.
And it's not even clear that
it's worth $200 million, maybe
the market is only willing
to pay $100 million.
But let's say the Fed comes in
and pays $200 million for it.
They would have to mark this
down to $200 million.
So that's $1.8 billion
writeoff.
Something that was worth
$2 billion is
now worth $200 million.
So if you write out $1.8
billion, then you're going to
have minus $800 million
of equity.
Or $0.8 billion of equity.
And then you would still
go bankrupt.
In fact, it would just
force the issue.
If the Fed were to go in and
buy at what they're calling
now fire sale prices,
but it's actually
probably an accurate price.
Even if they were to buy
slightly above that, but still
at a discount, it would
force this bank to
write down this asset.
It might have to then realize
negative equity.
And it would still create this
whole chain of events.
And so this is what the
Fed actually said.
They actually said no we
don't want to buy it
at fire sale prices.
I think Bernanke's exact words
were that, we're not going to
buy at fire sale prices, we're
going to buy at hold to
maturity prices.
So to me, what the Fed is
saying, we're going to pay
enough money for these assets so
that these banks still have
positive equity.
And so the these banks can still
pay off any liabilities
that come due.
Well you might say, well hey
Sal, that's not a bad idea.
And I say, that's
a horrible idea.
Because if these are really
worth $100 million, and you're
paying $2 billion for it, you're
essentially writing a
government check,
$1.9 billion.
Let's say this is really
worth minus $0.8.
Let's say that they're
really worth zero,
just to simplify things.
Let's say these are actually
worth zero and the government
pays $2 billion for it.
The government is essentially
writing a $2 billion check to
the equity holders
of this company.
The real equity is worth
minus $1 billion.
But the government is going to
essentially write them a $2
billion check so they can get
their billion dollars back.
And it's also going to benefit
the bond holders.
Because if this is worth zero,
not only will these guys get
wiped out, but then these guys
are only going to be able to
capture back some of
these $3 billion.
So these liabilities are going
to be written down.
These guys that are owed $4
billion are only going to be
able get $3 billion back.
So if the government were to pay
$2 billion for this, it's
essentially writing a $1
billion check to the
shareholders and a $1 billion
check to the bond holders or
the people who lent this
company money.
And essentially, those are
the worst people to be
writing a check to.
Because these are the people
who essentially lent money
that shouldn't have been lent.
These are people
who took risk.
They took all the reward over
the last five years and now
when the risk hits, the
government is essentially
having welfare for the
private sector.
So that in my mind is
the worst idea.
The government is arguing, I
know it's bad, and these are
the people we don't want to
reward, but by doing this, we
save the real economy.
Because by doing this,
we prevent this
cascade from happening.
And hopefully, these banks will
still lend to the farmer
and still lend to the the guy
who wants to build a factory.
In the next video I want to show
you one, why that might
not be the case.
That even if they were to do
this, as much as I disagree
with it, if it worked
maybe it's worth it.
But one, I'll argue that
it probably won't work.
And two, there are better
ways to do this.
More equitable, more fair
And we'll show you that
in the next video.